he's Jason Kelsey the Eagles Center
joining us on behalf of new Old Spice
beard care collection helping guys guys
to achieve the soft nourished and
sculpted beards of their dreams
he also wrote a poem it's a book the Old
Spice guys grooming guide with guys for
beards and other poems hi Jason how are
you today
spectacular how do you feel after
yesterday sore very sore everywhere it's
part of the NFL especially playing in
the trenches you know you know it adds
up especially out of you 89 please let
yesterday and you know the next day's
always a little rough but ok if you how
would you describe it to us since we'll
never play in an NFL game and certainly
you're playing offensive line so it's
not the same after every game I'll say
that usually the back of your neck feels
like the muscles just are extremely
fatigued your ankles and knees the older
you get just start to have this achy
feeling when you're trying to walk and
then you know your hands and shoulders
obviously as an offensive lineman you
just punch it with them over and over
and over again so you know your fingers
are in the day after your shoulders
right in front I don't know if anybody
has ever gotten into like am I to do
like a bench press or to I'm trying to
think of like a regular everyday
situation like you know you you know
when you get out of bed and you just get
out of bed and go to the bathroom and
it's completely normal
the day after getting out of bed is like
the first moment of when you realize
just how much you put your body yeah
like the first step you make gives you a
good feeling for how the ankles feel and
then the mobis stand completely up tells
you how your knees feel and then once
you start walking it tells you what your
hips are feeling like and
you know today and obviously as I get
older and as everybody gets older in the
league those aches and pains just
continue to add up can you tell the
difference between Carson Wentz's hands
and Nick Foles his hands under your butt
yes absolutely
I can tell the difference between
everybody's hands so I could be
blindfolded I'm pretty sure I could so
who was back there what's the difference
between Wednesday and polls when says
once has a very folds has a very large
hand and he applies a lot of pressure so
I I feel that and it's very intimidating
feeling Carson Carson is a much softer
hands but they're very affirmative you
know I think that he's a he's a very a
type personality controlling type guy
which is an awesome attribute to have in
a quarterback but I think that um you
know his are almost back there where you
can barely feel them right but as soon
as you snap the ball they're always in
the right spot do you ever feel sorry
for a quarterback after in like fourth
quarter ninety degree weather yeah
either a fourth quarter 90 degree
weather even in practice you know
they'll come to me and and you know
they're like - can you like maybe change
your pants Carson actually mentioned
that last year in games he's like and
this was early on in the season where
it's still hot out he's like you we
might have to start you know getting you
to change pants out in halftime and this
is just getting out of control I
actually got a really funny story with
Nick Foles after practice one day had
been taken under center snaps all game
long and he goes over to one of the
coaches wives that were really familiar
with she probably doesn't even know this
story but I'm not gonna name dropper um
okay you know live but um she goes up oh
my god so wonderful to see you
grabs Nick's hand and gives it a kiss Oh
oh yeah
so Oh Nick said I didn't even know what
to do I just I just let it happen
because I didn't even I didn't have
enough time to stop it oh man he's a
Jason Kelsey the Eagle Center joining a
stand Patrick show do you have what's a
typical call for the center when when
you because we don't hear you guys say
anything
sure so what happens when the audible or
whatever you're your call is sure so
it's different in different offenses our
offense we work off of a point and the
point is specific to the play so if
we're running an inside zone play to the
left to the open side meaning there's
not a tight end there the point is going
to be the will linebacker and dependent
on the defense that we get the
combination call is the next call so
let's say 54 zone is the will linebacker
in this formation that's who we want the
offensive line to start with then
everybody else knows you know who the
Mike linebacker is now considered to the
buck linebacker or the Sam linebacker is
not considered and that's it's all
counting right so the left tackle knows
he has the defensive end now my job is
to set up okay are we going to double
team the nose guard or am I just going
to let the left guard help the tackle at
the end up to the linebacker and that's
determined on the down lineman's
technique and then so once we figure out
what that combination call is going to
be then everybody else makes their calls
off of that call if it's in the passing
game while you're trying to find the
most dangerous of the guys that can
potentially blitz understand and this is
why it's so in crucial in my opinion for
quarterbacks to know what's going on you
know who's not going to be protected who
are you hot off of and all of that is
determined off at a point give me a call
you know give us a sample here in real
time oh man I don't like using our terms
I'm gonna give you an old term okay
we used to use R and L for a combination
on zone plays between the right guard
and left guard real complicating I'm
sure as you've already figured out Ella
means left guard and center R means
right garden center and if it's an
inside zone the L 2:54 like we were just
talking about would be a like a vertical
more vertical double team try and smash
the doubt and down linemen up to the
linebacker if it was an outside zone it
would be more like a scooping
combination between the center and left
guard just call it a fuse no matter what
Jay so just I'm wench and I'm calling
out blue 84 and now are you saying
anything then no blue 84 means nothing I
know but let's say I'm calling whatever
he's calling but when do you call that
your your signal your line that's it
yeah the line call happens way before
you started the cadence okay typically
typically we get up to the line line up
the defense presents how they're lining
up I make the call then Carson will
start at least the first cadence and
then if maybe one a double cadence
because we know that they're trying to
disguise something or they they're
moving away this makes a pole Jason I
know well we make the call first okay
here we go
sometimes you got to change the call
okay but you're not you're gonna stay
with this call damn this was a bad idea
to go with this line stuff all right go
all right so we come up to the ball okay
there are a standard over front l 54
then the right guard right tackle say B
250 and then Carson one starts his blue
84 who Eddie force it hot and then we
run into his own that's that's it okay I
love the new liner
I love the nuance of that we got your
brother on tomorrow when's the last time
you have fought him the last time I
fought him was the first time he was
able to beat me and basketball outside
of our house our home town house in
Cleveland Heights Ohio he was
sophomore at the time I was a senior in
high school and he had finally become
taller than me
and he kept doing this stupid hook shot
over and just he was draining it every
single time so of course being the older
brother I couldn't lose I started filing
them and then he started to lose and
tempers started to flare yada yada yada
the next thing we find ourselves in the
kitchen and we are in a full-blown
fistfight and I've been till that point
my little brother every time I had
punched him it was the end of the fight
and we didn't get into you know a lot of
fistfights I don't want to give that
impression but whenever I had punched
him before it was usually tears walk
away it's over this time I punch him and
he picks me up and slams me on the
kitchen floor locks the oven off of the
rack that it was actually sitting on and
we get to our feet were in a full fist
fight and the only thing that stopped
the fight was eventually I fell back on
top of my dad who grabbed me and he
screaming
I read you got some poems that you've
written for Old Spice do you have one or
two that you can read I do yes oh look
is the book and all the products are
available on amazon.com exclusively and
I'll start with this first one right
here okay it's all about delivery knock
knock who's there
your beard collection my what where
Amazon what do you think dude
I'm soaking it in I think I might go
back to okay what's your line calls you
know the line calls yeah okay give me
another poem there we go okay I'll give
you no one this one I got the man I
nursed I was I dreamt a dream about a
beard with Sheen what could it mean this
dreamy dream
was it about my beard with Sheen
probably all right I like that one
better I liked that one better better
yeah okay yeah I don't like I like that
one no no no no I like the effort all
for the effort do you guys like being
the underdogs again this year because it
feels like the Los Angeles Rams are the
media darlings
how did that happen you guys are
underdogs again well it's interesting
because I think that you do like being
the underdog but in reality we are the
defending champions and I think that
when people come into the Philadelphia
Eagle Stadium when they come into the
link
I don't think teams think of us as
younger dog I mean we bottle - I think
we're undefeated from last year to this
year at Lincoln Financial we still have
a phenomenal team so you know I like to
think of it like we're we're the top
dogs really maybe in the media's eyes
were still the underdogs but I think at
the end of the day we have a phenomenal
team of great coaching staff we've more
than earned the right to be respected in
this league and you know you know I
don't really think of it as quite the
same as last year
but the motivation is still there
obviously yeah embrace the underdog role
it's all right it certainly helped last
year it worked laughs yeah I'd embrace
it
give me the website here with the new
Old Spice beard care collection sure
yeah this the Old Spice beard care
collection is this is the first time Old
Spice has done this and it's available
exclusively on amazon.com or if you have
the Amazon app out assume it's on that
as well but the it's it's a pretty nice
box I wish I could show it to you I mean
you know they just do it right the
packaging everything it's just lined up
well and you know if you're looking for
the beard of your dreams you know a soft
nourish sculpted beard this is the
product for you thank you Jason it's
good to visit with you and good luck
against the Titans next week that's
Jason Kelsey for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]